hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt wie sie mir bereits gesagt hat
schminke ich sah mir heute zum toll und
zwar zum aktuellen kinofilmen die trolle
und verlierer wird poppy sein das ist
dieser weibliche troll hier und ich
zeige euch heute welche schminkt farben
ich verwende und wie man das ganz
einfach zu hause nachmachen kann bei den
schmink farben wahr wenn ich die theorie
farben die habe ich seit zwei bis drei
jahren schon im gebrauch und ich
verwende die ganz gerne weil sich sehr
gut auftragen lassen auch sehr einfach
auftragen lassen
und was mir persönlich ganz wichtig ist
sie lassen sich sehr einfach wieder
abwaschen also im vergleich zu anderen
farben sowieso und ich nehme hier heute
rot rosa weiß und schwarz
und wenn du einen kleinen wersen schwamm
den ich vorher befeuchtet
mit dem lässt sich gut auch tragen und
ich arbeite aber auch noch mit
verschiedenen inseln in verschiedenen
größen hobby hat eine ziemlich große
nase deswegen wird von mir jetzt auch
eine große nase bekommen und sv ried mit
etwas nachwuchs das kann man in
bastelbedarf online zum beispiel
besorgen und zwar ziemlich festes
material hat man raus
und das muss man jetzt einige minuten
weich kneten und das haben wir jetzt
bereits vorbereitet dann wird es nämlich
ganz schön weich nämlich eine etwas
größere kugeln und platzieren sie bei
samira auf der nase und verstreicht
sieger aus
mit befestige hier noch zwei kleinere
kugeln und es sind an die nasenflügel
als nächstes verwende ich das
transparent bruder von gregory und es
trage ich jetzt auch die nase auf damit
die schminke
praktisch haben jetzt sei es mit einem
pinsel auf und später gehe ich noch mal
mit dem schwamm drüber so geht's am
schnellsten
die schwerreichen stellen ein kleiner
zum abo oder nehme ich das transparent
bruder dadurch für die farbe auch ein
bisschen gestresst im gesicht
jetzt verwende ich eine ganz normale
lidschatten palette mehrere auch unter
schmitten und auch ein bisschen die
wangen dann zu definieren
jetzt denke ich doch ein bisschen puder
und es kommt dann auf ihre wangen
mit diesem setup oder kann man auch ganz
gut wenn man zum beispiel ein anderes
schminkt gesicht hat das gesicht
komplett grundieren
jetzt bekommen sie mir noch ein paar
wimpern angeklebt
bei mir ist fertig und ich finde
distanziert rollen ist auf der welt gibt
trete ich mal rum das jetzt schaue ich
von hinten aussehen die verrückte habe
ich hier aufgesetzt die haben wir von
dem film detroit und im hintergrund ist
noch ob die torte die pinkfarbene
verrückt gelb so bescheiden
dem hobby sondern und diskos team habe
ich ihr aus filz gemachte sich ganz
einfach bastl filz das haben zurecht
geschnitten und mit ein paar stich und
einfach zusammengenäht das ist wirklich
super einfach da muss man auch nicht
ganz genau sein
hier vorne noch den kragen und die blume
könnte man natürlich noch ein bisschen
kleiner machen aber ich find's super
bequem denn sie sich auch bewegen und
den spielen und rennen und supersüß ganz
toll filialen farben dass man die später
ganz einfach wieder wegwischen kann
wir machen einfach weg
genau so sommerer wird später bestimmen
denn die badewanne gehen weil einfach
der ganze körper voll mit farbe ist aber
ansonsten einfach mit warmem wasser
das heißt die farben sind auch für
kleine kinder zum beispiel sehr gut
geeignet wie gesagt waren das die farben
von bmi von kerling und wir sind
wirklich supergut in der anwendung uns
hat auch richtig viel spaß gemacht oder
extreme und essen und rollt orte oder
also ich hoffe euch hat das video spaß
gemacht und ich glaube uns beiden hat
viel spaß wie lange seid ihr braucht
jetzt zum schminken und für etwa
eineinhalb stunden also nicht länger
also bis zum nächsten mal
der zaun oft noch so tolle menschen und
ein troll groß machen also ca